I am here with mr. Romelu Lukaku on his
off day right yes so we're gonna spend
the day together show us around your
house and we're going to get to know him
a little bit more can you mix you have a
teammate's for my that big ones here is
I playing my xbox and playstation ok so
when you're playing Fifa are you playing
as you play every trick really what am I
getting each other because of that yeah
the kitchen this is your chef Elif
yes she's from Paris Roxy what about you
so you guys speak French you speak seven
languages it's very impressive
this is the cinnamon so fancy you know
because I haven't been you in the water
you have Sir Alex Ferguson book here
that somebody you would have liked to
play for yeah obviously yeah it's a nice
person
it's just like a cellphone rich it's a
smarter it yeah this is very bougie
French does Ramallah even know how to
use this fridge um I don't really know
so this fridge is just fancy for the
sake of being fancy just fancy but it
works so this Jersey it's one of the
first things you see once you get into
the house my first game for much - no -
[Music]
do you play anyone on the team one time
Jesse lingard came last year every
played you're gonna have to explain okay
this keyboard oh can you play it no why
do you have it because I like beats now
I know that sometimes you and Pogba will
do the beat he'll wrap yeah if you
better wrap the beat makers Ike if you
wanted beats are mixed like you have to
come to me would you guys ever like
release some other things are you done
no no no that's that's a dream that will
never happen